Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the number one success story in the history of land life. Not only did dinosaurs exercise an airtight monopoly as large land animals, they kept their commanding position for an extraordinary span of time 130 million years our own human species is no more than a hundred thousand years old true the dinosaurs are extinct but we ought to be careful in judging them inferior to our own kind who can say that the human system will last another thousand years let alone a. Now, that was the American paleontologist Robert T. Baca, a man of whom Tom Holland knows a great deal. Because Tom, you are a massive dinosaur enthusiast,
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，加入陆地生物历史上最成功的传奇。恐龙不仅作为大型陆地动物确立了牢不可破的绝对统治地位，它们还以惊人的时间跨度保持了这一统治地位——长达1.3亿年，而我们人类物种的历史不过十万年左右。诚然，恐龙已经灭绝，但在判断它们不如我们人类时，我们应当谨慎。谁能说人类的体系能再持续一千年，更不用说……现在，这是美国古生物学家罗伯特·T·巴克，汤姆·霍兰对这个人了解很多。因为汤姆，你是一个狂热的恐龙爱好者，
aren't you? You were interested in dinosaurs before you were interested in history. So dinosaurs is actually your real interest. Is that right? Yeah, dinosaurs is my number one passion, like lots of children. It was kind of my introduction to a world that was unlike the contemporary. So I would always kind of go up the lane behind a house and there'd be sheep or something. And I'd wish that they were tyrannosaurs or triceratops or whatever.
对吧？你对恐龙产生兴趣比对历史感兴趣还要早。所以恐龙实际上才是你真正的兴趣所在。是这样吗？是的，恐龙是我的头号热情所在，就像许多小孩子一样。它算是把我引入了一个与当代截然不同的世界。所以我总是会去我家房子后面的小路，那里有羊什么的。而我当时总希望它们是暴龙、三角龙或者别的什么。
And I think that the kind of glamour and the terror and the dread of the Mesozoic world is what kind of set me then up for the glamour and the dread and the terror of the Roman world. I kind of moved seamlessly along from, you know, Saurian apex predators to the Roman army as a kind of apex predator. And I must say that it's great on a history podcast. You know, we've been doing a lot of contemporary history recently, so it's absolutely brilliant. Yeah.
而且我认为，中生代世界的那种魅力、恐惧和敬畏，为我后来感受罗马世界的魅力、敬畏和恐惧奠定了基础。我仿佛无缝衔接，从（你知道的）蜥形纲顶级掠夺者过渡到了作为一种顶级掠夺者的罗马军队。我必须说，这在历史播客节目中太棒了。你知道的，我们最近做了很多当代历史，所以这绝对太精彩了。
To be going back millions and millions of years. Although we should point out, we're not doing that, are we? This is not about dinosaurs. Well, it's about dinosaurs in history, I suppose, isn't it? Yes, it's about historical. We're not suddenly turning into a paleontology podcast. This is about the process by which people came to realize that dinosaurs had existed and the role that they've played in the imagination
能回到数百万年前。尽管我们应该指出，我们其实并没有这么做，对吧？这并不是关于恐龙的节目。嗯，我想这是关于历史上的恐龙，对吧？是的，关于历史上的。我们并没有突然变成一个古生物学播客。这是关于人们如何开始意识到恐龙曾经存在的过程，以及它们在人们想象中所扮演的角色
since their discovery which i think is a completely fascinating topic it's a brilliant topic so let's um we have quite a few questions uh to kick off with so uh a good one from Drop Dead Gormless, Steve. He says, what's the earliest written record of the discovery of a fossil? Perhaps we can widen that out a tiny bit. What is the earliest point that we know that people are even aware of dinosaurs? It's a great question. And there's a wonderful book by Adrienne Mayer, who's a kind of she's in the intersection point between classicist and paleontologist and and she's looked at uh the records from ancient Greece from Rome uh and more recently um the legends that Native Americans have told about thunder beasts and kind of
自从它们被发现以来，我认为这是一个绝对迷人的话题，这是一个精彩的话题。那么，我们有相当多的问题要开头，所以……史蒂夫（Steve），来自“死得毫无防备”（Drop Dead Gormless）的一个好问题。他说，关于发现化石的最早文字记载是什么？也许我们可以把这个范围稍微拓宽一点。我们所知道的人们开始意识到恐龙存在的最早时间是什么时候？这是一个很好的问题。有一本精彩的书，作者是阿德里安娜·梅尔（Adrienne Mayer），她可以说是兼具古典学者和古生物学家双重身份的交叉型人物，她研究了古希腊、罗马的记录，以及最近美洲原住民讲述的关于雷兽和诸如此类的
creatures like that and her argument is that say in North America the stories are told about thunderbirds correspond to the discovery perhaps of pterosaurs in the kind of incredibly fossil rich bone yards of the wild west. I think that in a way the best problem is that lots of the bones that the Greeks and the Romans talk about are not dinosaurs because the Mediterranean does not play host to a dinosaur bearing fossil beds. But I think my favorite thesis that she has actually does relate to dinosaurs. And it also relates to Herodotus, who is my great hero as historian who I've translated. So I was particularly thrilled by Adrienne's thesis on this, which is that Herodotus reports that in a kind of distant land, there's mountains and deserts, and there are creatures called griffins that lay on eggs. And Adrian
生物的传说，她的论据是，比如说在北美，关于雷鸟的故事与在狂野西部极其丰富的化石骨床中发现翼龙相对应。我认为，在某种程度上，最好的问题是希腊人和罗马人谈论的许多骨骼并不是恐龙，因为地中海并没有恐龙化石层。但我认为她实际提出的我最喜欢的论点确实与恐龙有关。这还与希罗斯（Herodotus）有关，他是我作为历史学家的伟大英雄，我翻译过他的作品。所以我对阿德里安娜关于这一点的论点感到特别兴奋，即希罗多德报道说，在一个偏远的土地上有山脉和沙漠，那里有被称为狮鹫的生物，它们在蛋上孵卵。而阿德里安娜·
Mayer's argument is that this is, well, literally a Chinese whisper, because this is, she says, perhaps a kind of garbled traveler's report from the Gobi Desert in Mongolia, just north of China, of the discovery of what in effect is a dinosaur called Protoceratops, which is a beaked dinosaur. So you think of Triceratops, this is a Triceratops without any horns. And its eggs are kind of scattered all around, just waiting to be found. These were the first ever fossilized dinosaur eggs that anyone discovered in the 1920s. And so she says, perhaps this legend of the griffin is a kind of report about the fossils of the skulls
梅尔的论点是，这，嗯，简直就是“传话游戏”（以讹传讹），因为她认为这也许是来自中国正北方的蒙古戈壁滩的某种被歪曲的旅行者报告，发现了实际上被称为原角龙的恐龙，这是一种有喙的恐龙。所以你想想三角龙，这就是没有角的三角龙。它的蛋散落四处，正等待着被发现。这些是人们在20世纪发现的有史以来第一批化石恐龙蛋。所以她说，也许狮鹫的传说正是关于原角龙等头骨化石从岩石中风化出来的某种报道。这是一个美妙的——我的意思是，这有点无法证明，但这是一个绝妙的想法。
of Protoceratops weathering out of rock or whatever. It's a wonderful, I mean, it's kind of unprovable, but it is a great idea. That then raises a big question there, an obvious question in which I'm sure listeners will have thought of. What about dragons? I i mean dragons are a brilliant subject in and of themselves but is there are quite a few listeners asked about this um on twitter are dragons basically some sort of weird memory of dinosaurs not called john and many others say our notes
这就引发了一个重大问题，一个听众们肯定都会想到的显眼问题。那龙呢？我的意思是，龙本身就是一个精彩的主题，但是有很多听众在推特上问了关于这个的问题，龙基本上是不是某种对恐龙的奇怪记忆，而不叫约翰和其他许多人问了关于恐龙和龙的问题，你怎么看？我不想深入探讨龙，因为我认为我们要专门做一集关于龙的节目。但是有这样的例子。例如，曾有报道称，一个罗马人去往如今的黎巴嫩。据说，这就是珀耳修斯用戈耳工的头把即将吞噬安德罗梅达的海怪变成石头的地方。他带回了被认为并声称是从海中升起的这只石化怪兽。而这很明显地被认为是被带回来的某种化石野兽，并被与龙或海怪之类的东西联系起来。我的意思是，也许吧。我的意思是，有……我认为说明问题的是，龙特别与中国有关，而且
asked about dinosaurs and dragons what do you think I don't want to go too deeply into dragons because I think we're going to do an episode specifically on them. But there is. So, for instance, there is a report of a Roman who travels to what's now the Lebanon. And this is where Perseus with the Gorgon's head is supposed to have turned the sea monster that was about to devour Andromeda into stone. And he brings back what is thought and claimed to be this petrified monster that's risen up from the sea. And that is pretty clearly assumed that that is some fossilized beast that's being brought back and it's being associated with dragons or sea monsters or whatever. I mean, I guess so, perhaps. I mean, there are, I think it's telling that the dragon is particularly associated with China and
中国拥有极其丰富的含化石岩石。所以是的，可能吧。事实上，有趣的是，已知最早的尝试根据化石进行模型塑造的例子是一座龙的雕像。它位于奥地利的一个名叫克拉根福（Klagenfurt）的小镇。据说那里曾经有一条龙，它捕食处女、吃牲口，做着龙所做的一切事情。然后一个勇敢的骑士出现并杀死了它。直到今天，这条龙仍然出现在克拉根福的城徽上。我想在16世纪，大概是那个时候，他们委托制作了它的雕像。他们发现了一个他们认为是山洞里龙的头骨的东西，因此克拉根福这座雕塑上的龙首，就对应着
China has incredibly rich fossil bearing rocks. So yes, probably. Actually, interestingly, the first known attempt to model something based on a fossil that we know is a statue of a dragon. It's in an Austrian town called Klagenfurt. And there was a there was supposedly a dragon there that was kind of preying on virgins and eating cattle and doing all the kind of stuff that a dragon does. And a brave knight comes along and kills it. And the dragon to this day is on the coat of arms of Klagenfurt. And I think in the 16th century, I think it was, they commissioned a statue of it. They had found what they thought was the skull of the dragon in the cave and so the head of the dragon on this sculpture in clagenford corresponds to um the contours of this skull that was found um the only problem is is it's not a dinosaur skull it's actually a skull of a woolly rhinoceros oh that
这个被发现的头骨的轮廓。唯一的毛病在于，它不是恐龙头骨，实际上是披毛犀的头骨。哦，那是……
was only yeah later so that reminds me of a story that i read in a brilliant essay written by a leading historian in the guardian, I think it was, of all newspapers, about five or six years ago. The historian was you, and you were talking about Tiberius. Oh. Well, don't pretend to be surprised, because you emailed it to me yesterday. This, by the way, is how Tom Holland behaves.
哦，这让我想起了一个故事，我读于大约五六年前，由《卫报》（我想是这份报纸）的一位顶尖历史学家写的一篇精彩文章。这位历史学家就是你，你当时在谈论提比略。哦。好吧，别假装惊讶，因为你昨天才把它发邮件给我。顺便说一句，这就是汤姆·霍兰的行为方式。
When he goes on holiday to Greece, where he now is, he spends his time emailing me his own old essays um so so Tiberius Tiberius Tiberius came across a tooth or was sent a tooth after an earthquake is that right something like this that's right in what's now Turkey um and it's uh yeah you can tell it you've heard my essay I'm not going to read your essay for you. That would be absolutely shaming. So there's an earthquake. Pliny the Elder says it's the worst earthquake in human memory.
当他去希腊度假时（他现在就在那里），他把时间都花在给我发他自己以前的写的文章上。所以……提比略、提比略、提比略在一次地震后偶然发现了一颗牙齿，或者说收到了一颗牙齿，是这样吗？类似这样的事情。没错，在现在的土耳其境内。是的，你可以看出你听过我的文章，我不会为你朗读你的文章。那绝对太丢脸了。所以发生了一场地震。老普林尼（Pliny the Elder）说这是人类记忆中最严重的一次地震。
And Tiberius has a tooth and he gets a mathematician. Is that right? To build a statue based on the tooth? Yeah. And it's absolutely huge. And the tooth is probably a mastodon. How do you know?
提比略有一颗牙齿，他找了一位数学家。是这样的吗？根据这颗牙齿建造一座雕像？是的。而且它绝对巨大。这颗牙齿可能属于乳齿象。你怎么知道？
How does anyone know? Prehistoric elephant. Because there were a lot of elephants, prehistoric elephants there and actually an interesting example of, so they assumed that this tooth was human. I mean, it couldn't have been human because obviously they weren't giant humans. But on the neighbouring island of Samos,
怎么会有人知道？史前大象。因为那里有很多大象，史前大象，实际上这是一个有趣的例子：所以他们认为这颗牙齿是人类的。我的意思是，它不可能是人类的，因为显然没有人类巨人。但在邻近的萨摩斯岛上，
just across from the A um the aegean coast the asian asian aegean coast so one of the greek islands they found all kinds of of bones and they worked out that these were elephant bones and so they they said that these were elephants that had been brought by dionysus when he came with a giant army from india to conquer greece so as far as i know that is the earliest correct identification of a prehistoric fossil and its identification with the kind of animal it really was yeah so obviously the the woolly rhinoceros skull at clagenfurt they got it completely wrong it wasn't a dragon yeah but it's an ancient greek story about um elephants coming from india yeah they did get
就在爱琴海海岸对面（亚洲爱琴海海岸，也就是其中一个希腊岛屿），他们发现了各种各样的骨头，他们研究出这些都是大象的骨头，所以他们说这些大象是狄奥尼索斯（Dionysus）带着庞大的军队从印度来征服希腊时带来的。据我所知，这是对史前化石及其与它真正属于的动物的种类的最早的正确识别。是的，所以显然克拉根福的披毛犀头骨，他们完全搞错了，它不是一条龙。是的，但这却是一个关于来自印度的象的古希腊故事。是的，他们确实搞对了，
it right they did get it right and then obviously a moment that will excite you the coming of christianity um there are no dinosaurs in the bible there's no there are no dinosaurs in the kind of mid there's a beast called behemoth right you could i mean it sounds a bit like a kind of uh a brachiosaur or something it's it's it's a colossal land animal that makes the earth shake and there's another there's a there's a marine one called leviathan but there's no there's no mesozoic era in the book of genesis though is there i mean no there isn't and obviously then in the christian kind of sense of time you know all these people bishops and saints kind of people trying to work out when god created the earth and all when abraham lived and all stuff. They have no sense of dinosaurs then. So for generations, people live in complete and utter ignorance of a prehistoric dinosaur era.
他们确实搞对了。然后，显而易见，一个会让你兴奋的时刻——基督教的降临。圣经中没有恐龙，圣经中没有……中间没有恐龙。有一种叫做“贝希摩斯”（Behemoth）的巨兽，对吧？你可以……我的意思是，它听起来有点像某种腕龙之类的东西。它是一种巨大的陆地动物，能让大地颤抖。还有另一种，有一种海洋巨兽叫做“利维坦”（Leviathan）。但在《创世记》中并没有中生代，对吧？我的意思是，没有，确实没有。显然，在基督教的这种时间观念中，所有人——主教们、圣人们——都在试图计算上帝创造地球的时间，以及亚伯拉罕生活的时期等等。他们当时根本没有恐龙的概念。所以好几代人都在对史前恐龙时代完全一无所知的情况下生活，
Am I right? They assume that creation happened. Well, I mean, the notorious example of that is in the 17th century, 1650, James Usher, who was the archbishop of Armagh. Yes. He tries to work out when the creation happened, and he goes through all the ancient texts, the classical texts, and so on. But of course, ultimately, his prime authority is the Bible, which takes him back to the creation.
我说的对吗？他们认为创世发生了。好吧，我的意思是，一个臭名昭著的例子是在17世纪，即1650年，阿马尔（Armagh）大主教詹姆斯·乌瑟（James Usher）。是的。他试图计算创世发生的时间，他查阅了所有的古代文本、古典文本等等。但当然，最终他最主要的权威是《圣经》，这把他带回了创世之时。
And he works out notoriously that it was 4004 BC. And this is always kind of cited as a hilarious example of gullibility of Christians. But actually, it's a pioneering attempt to work out just how far back you can push the beginnings of time. And I think that from the point of view of discovering the existence of dinosaurs, you need to have a sense that the earth is old and that it had a beginning. And actually, and it probably won't surprise you to hear me say this, Christianity is quite important in this. Because what Christianity, like Judaism or Islam or before that Zoroastrianism, from which it gets the idea, it posits that there's a beginning and an end. And so time, rather than being cyclical, it starts. That origin point just gets pushed back further and further and further. And I think it's telling that the people who often who do that are themselves kind of Christian priests, of whom the most interesting is a guy who we've already come across yes uh and he came i mentioned him in the
他臭名昭著地计算出那是公元前4004年。这总是被当作基督徒轻信的荒谬例子而被引用。但实际上，这是为了弄清楚你能把时间的起点推溯到多远的一次开创性尝试。我认为，从发现恐龙存在的角度来看，你需要有一种意识，即地球很古老，它曾有一个起点。而且，听到我这么说你可能不会感到惊讶，基督教在这方面非常重要。因为正如犹太教、伊斯兰教或在此之前的琐罗亚斯德教（它从中获得了这一理念）一样，基督教断言存在着起点和终点。因此，时间不是循环的，而是有开端的。那个起源点被不断地向后、向后、再向后推。我认为很有说明意义的是，经常做这件事的人本身就是基督教神职人员，其中最有趣的是我们已经遇到过的一个家伙，是的……
the french revolution episode because he's the guy who ate the heart of louis the 14th so he's william buckland yeah william buckland so william buckland was operating just down the road from where i am now because i'm in chipping norton and there's stuff about him in churchill the next village just down the road so he's a clergyman, isn't he? He's a professor of geology at Oxford University. And he ends up being at Westminster. I mean, he's extraordinarily big. And so he's basically the founding father of dinosaur studies.
他来……我在法国大革命那一集里提到过他，因为他是那个吃掉路易十四心脏的家伙，所以他就是威廉·巴克兰（William Buckland）。是的，威廉·巴克兰。所以威廉·巴克兰活动的地方离我现在所在的地方不远，因为我在奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton），离这儿不远的丘吉尔村（Churchill）就有关于他的东西。所以他是一个神职人员，对吧？他是牛津大学的地质学教授。他最终在威斯敏斯特任职。我的意思是，他非常了不起。所以他基本上是恐龙研究的鼻祖。
Am I right? He coins the word megalosaurus. He comes up with that word. Yes, a great lizard. He does. megalosaurus he comes up with that word yes so great lizard he he does and megalosaurus is the first creature to be to get a kind of proper scientific linnaean name so you know the the means of of um uh defining living organisms coined by the the swedish um naturalist linnaeus carlinas yeah but there is there is a brilliant complication to this story.
我说的对吗？他创造了“巨龙”（Megalosaurus）这个词。他想出了那个词。是的，“伟大的蜥蜴”。他确实做到了。Megalosaurus，他想出了那个词。是的，“伟大的蜥蜴”。他确实做到了，而且Megalosaurus是第一个获得某种正规的科学林奈式命名的生物，所以你知道，由瑞典自然学家卡尔·林奈（Carl Linnaeus）所创造的定义生物有机体的方法……卡尔·林奈。是的。但这个故事还有一个精彩而复杂的转折。
So yes, so the megalosaur bones are found in the Stainesville quarries where lots of the stone for the Cotswolds, cottages that you love, come from. Actually, a thigh bone of a megalosaur was found there back in the 17th century. And it was given to a guy called Robert Plott, who was, I think, professor of chemistry. He was the founder of the Ashmolean Museum in Oxford. And he studies it and works out what it is. And he has no idea what it could be. So he thinks, you know, is it a Roman war elephant?
所以是的，巨龙的骨头是在斯坦斯维尔（Stainesville）采石场发现的，你所喜爱的科茨沃尔德（Cotswolds）村舍的许多石材就产自那里。实际上，早在17世纪，那里就发现了一根巨龙的大腿骨。它被交给了罗伯特·普洛特（Robert Plott），他好像是化学教授。他是牛津阿什莫林博物馆（Ashmolean Museum）的创始人。他对其进行研究并弄清了它是什么。但他根本不知道它可能是什么。所以他想，你知道，这是罗马战象吗？
Again, does it come from a giant, one of the biblical giants? You can't really work it out. Anyway, that vanishes, but somebody makes a drawing of it. And midway through the 18th century, another guy comes across this drawing and he looks at it and he thinks it looks like a scrotum.
话说回来，它是来自巨人、某个圣经巨兽吗？你真的搞不懂。不管怎样，那块骨头消失了，但有人画了它的图。到了18世纪中叶，另一个人偶然看到了这幅画，他看了看，觉得它看起来像一个阴囊。
And so he gives it the Linnaean name scrotum humanum. And under the universally accepted laws of scientific nomenclature, it's the first name that has to apply. So Megalosaurus is actually not. It should probably be known as scrotum humanum. That's the first dinosaur, which is a brilliant story. That's a terrible indignity for that dinosaur, isn't it? And for dinosaurs in general. Yes, it really is. I think paleontologists agree that they're not going to run with that.
于是他给它起了个林奈学名：Scrotum humanum（人类阴囊）。根据普遍接受的科学命名法规则，这是必须适用的第一个名称。所以巨龙实际上并不是……它大概应该被称为“人类阴囊”。这是第一只恐龙，这是一个绝妙的故事。这对那只恐龙来说是一种可怕的羞辱，对吧？对恐龙整体也是如此。是的，确实如此。我想古生物学家一致认为他们不会沿用这个名字。
So Buckland kind of identifies it as this giant ancient reptile. I think in 1822, he publicly presents it in 1824. Meanwhile, there's another guy, crucial guy, a doctor called Gideon Mantel. This is the fellow in Sussex. Sussex, yeah. And again in 1822, he's paying a visit. His wife goes off to a quarry and she discovers this tooth, which Mantel, with the help of the great French anatomist, 1822, he's paying a visit. His wife goes off to a quarry and she discovers this tooth,
所以巴克兰有点把它认定为这种巨大的古代爬行动物。我想是在1822年，他在1824年公开展示了它。与此同时，还有另一个人，一个关键人物，一位名叫吉ideon·曼特尔（Gideon Mantell）的医生。这就是萨塞克斯（Sussex）的那位伙计。萨塞克斯，是的。同样是在1822年，他在拜访……他的妻子去了一个采石场，她发现了这颗牙齿，曼特尔在伟大的法国解剖学家乔治·居维叶（Georges Cuvier）的帮助下，在1822年，他在拜访……他的妻子去了一个采石场，她发现了这颗牙齿，
which Mantel, with the help of the great French anatomist, Georges Cuvier, identifies as belonging to an iguana. Perhaps it looks like an iguana, you know, kind of the lizards. Hence iguanodon. Yes, it's a tooth of an iguana. Over the course of the succeeding years, Mantel discovers kind of more and more bits of Iguanodon. He discovers the bones of another giant ancient creature that he calls Hyliosaurus.
曼特尔在伟大的法国解剖学家乔治·居维叶的帮助下，将其鉴定为属于一只鬣蜥。也许它看起来像一只鬣蜥，你知道的，某种蜥蜴。因此有了“禽龙”（Iguanodon）这个名字。是的，这是一颗鬣蜥的牙齿。在随后的几年里，曼特尔发现了越来越多关于禽龙的碎片。他又发现了另一种巨大古代生物的骨头，他将其命名为“林龙”（Hyliosaurus）。
So there are these three land-based monsters, Megalosaurus, Hyliosaurus, Iguanodon. what they are until in 1842, probably the greatest and the most unpleasant scientific figure in Victorian Britain. The most unpleasant? He's a horrible man. He's a guy called Richard Owen. He's a great man. I mean, he founds
所以有这三种陆地怪物：巨龙、林龙、禽龙。它们到底是什么，直到1842年，维多利亚时代英国最伟大也是最令人讨厌的科学人物出现了。最令人讨厌？他是个可怕的人。他叫理查德·欧文（Richard Owen）。他是个伟人。我的意思是，他创立了
the Natural History Museum and he coins the word dinosauria. So terrible lizards. But he's an awful man and he gets into a terrible feud with poor Mantel and basically drives him to an early grave. So Richard Owen refuses to allow Mantel kind of any credit for what he's doing. He mocks his conclusions.
自然历史博物馆，并且他创造了“恐龙”（Dinosauria）这个词。意为恐怖的蜥蜴。但他是个糟糕透顶的人，他跟可怜的曼特尔结下了可怕的仇怨，基本上把曼特尔逼向了早逝。所以理查德·欧文拒绝给予曼特尔对他的工作的任何赞誉。他嘲笑曼特尔的结论。
He brands him a fraud. He drives Mantel basically to bankruptcy. Mantell's wife leaves him. His son runs away to Australia. Mantell, ultimate indignity, he has to move from, he gets so poor that he has to move from Sussex to Clapham Common. Oh, that is love. And at Clapham Common, he gets entangled in the reins of a runaway cab.
他污蔑曼特尔为骗子。他基本上把曼特尔逼到了破产的境地。曼特尔的妻子离开了他。他的儿子逃到了澳大利亚。曼特尔遭受了终极羞辱，他不得不从萨塞克斯搬家，他变得如此贫困，以至于不得不从萨塞克斯搬到克拉普罕阔街（Clapham Common）。哦，那太凄凉了。而在克拉普罕阔街，他被一辆失控的出租马车的缰绳缠住了。
He gets dragged along the street. He gets scoliosis. And he ends up taking an opium overdose to control the pain and dying. And this is all the fault of the bloke who founded the Natural History Museum. That seems a bit... And the worst thing is that Richard Witt takes his body and keeps his skeleton in a jar. Okay, that's pretty weird.
他被沿着街道拖行。他患上了脊柱侧弯。最后他为了控制疼痛而服用了过量的鸦片并死去了。而这一切都是因为那个创立了自然历史博物馆的家伙的过错。这听起来有点……而最糟糕的是，理查德·欧文拿走了他的尸体，把他的骨骼泡在一个罐子里。好吧，那真是相当诡异。
He's twisted, you know, he's got the scoliosis, so his spine is twisted. So poor Gideon Mattel, being persecuted to death by Richard Owen, ends up in a jar. And then I think they threw it out in the 60s. It was in the surplus to requirements.
他身体扭曲了（你知道的，他得了脊柱侧弯，所以他的脊椎是扭曲的）。所以可怜的吉迪恩·曼特尔被理查德·欧文迫害至死后，最终被装在了一个罐子里。然后我想他们在20世纪60年代把它扔掉了。因为它被认为是不再需要的剩余物资。
So this poor man. I can think of it. Wow. That's given me a whole new way of thinking about my enemies and the punishments I will visit upon them one day. So Owen kind of got his punishment because he got in a massive bust up with Darwin and opposed Darwin.
所以这个可怜的人。我能想得通。哇。这让我对我的敌人以及我将来要对他们施加的惩罚有了一种全新的思考方式。所以欧文某种程度上得到了他的惩罚，因为他和达尔文大吵了一架，并且反对达尔文。
So he ended up kind of on the losing side. But, I mean, he was a huge thing. And actually, there was always a large statue of Richard Owen in the Natural History Museum, which then got moved and replaced with one of Darwin. So in a sense, the ghost of Gideon Mantell. He was laughing. He would have enjoyed that.
所以他最终落得个失败者的下场。但是，我的意思是，他曾经是个大人物。事实上，自然历史博物馆里一直立着一尊巨大的理查德·欧文雕像，后来它被移走，换成了一尊达尔文的雕像。所以从某种意义上说，吉迪恩·曼特尔的幽灵。他当时在笑。他会很享受那一幕的。
But the other thing that Richard Owen does is to, he teams up with a guy called Benjamin Waterhousehouse hawkins who is a sculptor in the wake of the great exhibition and the great exhibition you know the crystal palace gets moved to south london and as part of that they think that they're going to have a kind of a prehistoric diorama and so they start building models of um of of these dinosaurs that Owen has just named. And famously, they get it wrong because Owen has got it wrong. And one of the things that Owen and Mantel had been arguing over was whether, for instance, Megalosaurus and Iguanodon,
但理查德·欧文做的另一件事是，他与一个名叫本杰明·沃特豪斯·霍金斯（Benjamin Waterhouse Hawkins）的雕塑家合作，在万国博览会之后（万国博览会的水晶宫被搬到了伦敦南部），作为其中的一部分，他们觉得要建造一个史前立体模型，于是他们开始建造欧文刚刚命名的这些恐龙的模型。
were they bipedal or were they quadrupeds? Mantel had argued correctly that Iguanodon was bipedal or were they quadrupeds and tell the dog incorrectly that iguanodon was bipedal so still on its hind feet um owen said no they're kind of massive squat tank like creatures and so that's how they are built so if you go to crystal Palace today you look at them I mean they're they're absolutely fabulous they're if you haven't been to the mirror in South London do go and see them they're're really wonderful. So they're kind of the very first dinosaur theme park. But Owen has got them very, very badly wrong. And as a famous, as part of the publicity for this, famously they have a kind of, I think it's New Year's Eve,
众所周知，他们弄错了，因为欧文弄错了。欧文和曼特尔一直在争论的一个问题是，例如，巨龙和禽龙是两足行走的，还是四足行走的？曼特尔正确地认为禽龙是两足行走的，或者是四足行走的，而曼特尔错误地认为禽龙是两足行走的——哦不，依然是用后脚站立的——欧文说不，它们是某种巨大的、蹲着的、像坦克一样的生物，所以它们就是那样被建造的。所以如果你今天去水晶公园（Crystal Palace）看它们，我的意思是——它们绝对棒极了。如果你没去过伦敦南部的那个地方，一定要去看看，它们真的很奇妙。所以它们可以说是最早的恐龙主题公园。但欧文把它们彻底搞错了。作为宣传活动的一部分，正如人们所知，我想那是在大年夜，
they have a dinner, New Year's Eve in 1853, I think it is, they have a dinner inside the Iguanodon as a kind of publicity thing. And Tom, why is this all happening in Britain? Or are similar things happening somewhere else? Is it that Britain is more, I don't know, I mean, there are other countries, France, for example, or Germany,
他们举行了一场晚宴，1853年的大年夜，我想是那一天，他们在一只禽龙的肚子里举办了一场晚宴，作为一种宣传活动。汤姆，为什么这一切都发生在英国？还是说类似的事情也在其他地方发生？是因为英国更……我不知道，我的意思是，还有其他国家，例如法国或德国（或者后来的德国），在科学上非常先进。为什么他们没有取得类似的长足进展？这真的很有趣。
or becomes Germany later on, are very scientifically advanced. Why aren't they making similar strides? It's really interesting. so people are discovering them so for instance um people are finding uh pterosaurs so that's flying wing flying reptiles from um from the mesozoic say in german quarries but they're not putting and they're finding giant aquatic creatures in belgium and and holl. But they're not putting, and they're finding giant aquatic creatures in Belgium and Holland, but they're not kind of bundling it together.
所以人们确实在发现它们——例如，人们正在发现翼龙——也就是来自中生代的会飞的爬行动物，比方说在德国的采石场里，但他们没有把它们组合起来。他们在比利时和荷兰发现了巨大的水生生物，但他们没有把它们组合起来。
And I think it's something to do with, well, we were talking about the Industrial Revolution yesterday. It's the scale with which people in Britain are kind of looking at the land because it's to do with extraction of coal. It's to do with the, um, the blasting of rock increasingly in the railway,
我想这与……好吧，我们昨天在谈论工业革命。这与英国人审视土地的规模有关，因为这与煤炭开采有关。这与铁路建设中岩石的爆破有关，
all that kind of stuff that there's a need to understand the geology of Britain. And so therefore, when you're looking at the geology, inevitably you're starting to find all these fossils. And there's a kind of, there's just a kind of curiosity about it and a kind of range of kind of mingled amateurs and men of science who kind of just put it together. So I think that one of the things that's really interesting
诸如此类的事情，使得人们有必要了解英国的地质状况。因此，当你审视地质时，你不可避免地开始发现所有这些化石。这里有一种好奇心，以及由混杂的业余爱好者和科学界人士组成的群体，他们把这些碎片拼凑在了一起。所以我认为，关于恐龙最有趣的事情之一，
about dinosaurs is the way that their discovery is kind of associated with the Industrial Revolution. So even though they are expressions of a kind of unimaginably distant past, and people find it incredibly destabilizing, of course, to realize that actually time is much, much deeper than they'd anticipated, they are also kind of cutting edge, which is why they appear at the Crystal Palace, which is this great monument to British know-how and get up and go. And it's why in Bleak House, in the opening paragraph,
就是它们的发现与工业革命息息相关。因此，尽管它们是某种难以想象的遥远过去的表现形式，而且人们发现，意识到时间实际上比他们预期的要深远得多，这具有极大的颠覆性，但它们同时也处于时代的前沿，这就是为什么它们会出现在水晶宫（这座英国技术和进取精神的伟大丰世纪纪念碑）中。这也是为什么在《荒凉山庄》（Bleak House）的开篇段落中，
Dickens fixes on, you know, he describes the mists that are kind of filling London. And he says that it wouldn't be a surprise to see a megalosaurus walking up Hoban Hill. He is, you know, that's a cutting edge reference. Yeah. Absolutely cutting edge reference. So it's sort of pushing the frontiers of science, isn't it?
狄更斯聚焦于（你知道的）他描述了弥漫伦敦的雾气。他说，看到一只巨龙走上霍本山（Hoban Hill）也不会让人感到意外。他（你知道的）这是一个非常前沿的引用。是的，绝对前沿的引用。所以它有点在推动科学的边界，对吧？
I suppose, forwards and backwards, as it were. Now, I was about to say, we've got a few questions about the Victorians. So maybe this is a good place to do them. Alyssa McCarthy has a question about gentleman collectors. How much are gentleman collectors driving this sort of, the progress in paleontology? And Mark Kirk Alves has a question that I wanted to ask,
我想，可以说是向前推进，也可以说是向后追溯。现在，我正要说，我们有几个关于维多利亚时代的问题。所以这也许是一个解答它们的好时机。阿莉莎·麦卡锡（Alyssa McCarthy）有一个关于绅士收藏家的问题。绅士收藏家在多大程度上推动了这种古生物学的进步？马克·柯克·阿尔维斯（Mark Kirk Alves）有一个我一直想问的问题，
which is about Mary Anning. So Mary Anning operated Lion Regis. And basically, I think by internationally approved binding laws, all British children now have to learn about Mary Anning. And it's unthinkable that they don't. Mark Kirk Alves says, did she really play a role or were we just desperate to make the subject relatable to girls? So is it gentleman collectors?
那是关于玛丽·安宁（Mary Anning）的。所以玛丽·安宁在莱姆里吉斯（Lyme Regis）活动。基本上，我认为根据国际公认的具有约束力的法律，现在所有的英国儿童都必须了解玛丽·安宁。他们不知道这一点是不可想象的。马克·柯克·阿尔维斯说，她真的发挥了作用，还是说我们只是拼命想让这个主题对女孩来说更具亲和力？所以是绅士收藏家吗？
Does Mary Anning matter? What's the story? It is gentleman collectors because William Buckland and Gillian Mantell and people like that, they're all gentlemen, essentially. And you have to be a gentleman. You have to be of gentle breeding and you have to be a man to get your papers accepted by the requisite societies,
玛丽·安宁重要吗？背后的故事是什么？确实是绅士收藏家，因为威廉·巴克兰、吉迪恩·曼特尔和类似的人，本质上都是绅士。而且你必须是一位绅士。你必须出身于绅士阶层，你必须是一个男人，才能让你的论文被所需的学会接受，
which is why Mary Anning is marginalized through her life. Absolutely. I mean, she is an astonishing figure. It's not just... So just give us a sense of who she is, Tom, for those listeners. So the reason that I haven't mentioned Mary Anning up to now is that this is about dinosaurs and dinosaurs are land... She's fossils, right? She's absolutely fossils. Dinosaurs are land-based. Mary Anning is discovering creatures that swam in the seas.
这就是为什么玛丽·安宁在她的一生中被边缘化。绝对是的。我的意思是，她是一个令人惊叹的人物。这不仅仅是……汤姆，请为那些听众大致介绍一下她是谁。我之所以到现在还没提到玛丽·安宁，是因为这是关于恐龙的，而恐龙是陆地的……她是关于化石的，对吧？她绝对是关于化石的。恐龙是陆地生物。玛丽·安宁发现的是在海里游动的生物。
So at the time, most of Dorset was underwater. Yeah. So that's why Mary Anning is finding ichthyosaurs, which kind of look like, you know, dolphins. She's finding plesiosaurs, which is the Loch Ness monster type, with the long neck and the flippers she is discovering pterosaurs she's identifying coprolites which are basically fossilized turds and she she's an amazing amazing pioneer and she she comes from the most kind of
所以在那个时候，多塞特郡（Dorset）的大部分地区都在水下。是的。这就是为什么玛丽·安宁发现了鱼龙（Ichthyosaurs），它们看起来有点像海豚。她发现了蛇颈龙（Plesiosaurs），也就是尼斯湖水怪那种类型的，有长脖子和鳍状肢。她正在发现翼龙。她正在识别粪化石（coprolites），也就是基本上是化石化的粪便。她是一个了不起的、了不起的先驱，她出身于极其
grinding poverty she as a child was she was under a tree with three women and lightning struck and all the women died of the lightning strike and she survived. And the theory was, in Lyme Regis, this had kind of given her a spark of curiosity. I mean, she learned to read and write, but she had no real kind of scholarly background greater than that and yet she achieves this kind of revolution in the understanding of the past that the scale of her discoveries and her ability to understand what it is that she's finding is amazing and they get essentially they kind of get um the uh the gentleman scholars are like jackals feeding on her kills and she doesn't really get any of it. There's one hero in this, which is a guy called Henry de la Biche, who is an illustrator who illustrates what is effectively the very first illustration of a prehistoric landscape.
水深火热的贫困之中。她小时候和三个女人在一棵树下，结果闪电击中了她们，所有的女人都在雷击中丧生，而她活了下来。在莱姆里吉斯，当时的理论认为，这赋予了她好奇心的火花。我的意思是，她学会了读写，但除此之外她没有任何真正的学术背景，然而她却实现了对过去理解的这一革命，她的发现规模以及她理解自己所发现的事物的能力是惊人的，而他们基本上……绅士学者们就像在猎物身上进食的胡狼一样，而她却没有真正得到任何成果。这里面有一个英雄，那就是一个名叫亨利·德拉比什（Henry de la Biche）的家伙，他是一位插画家，绘制了实际上是史前风景的第一幅插图。
And in Latin, it's called Dorset as it was long long ago um and it you know it shows long-necked plesiosaurs kind of crunching on um uh pterosaurs and it shows ichthyosaurs and there's you know marianne has basically discovered that she's she's advanced his thesis that um feces can be fossilized and there's i think it's i think it's a plesiosaur who's in the process of being munched to death, literally shitting himself. And you can see these kind of turns dropping down to the bottom of the sediment, the bottom of the sea, where they in due course will be fossilized and then be discovered by Mary Anning. So she's a massive figure, but she's not discovering dinosaurs because Lyme Regis is in the Mesozoic with sea, not land. So I wanted to ask about Christianity because we're in the mid-Victorian period,
拉丁语中，它被称为“昔日多塞特”（Dorset as it was long long ago），它（你知道的）展示了长脖子的蛇颈龙在咀嚼……翼龙，它展示了鱼龙，还有（你知道的）玛丽·安宁基本上已经发现并推进了他的论题——粪便可以被化石化，我想这是一只正在被活活咀嚼致死的蛇颈龙，字面意义上吓得屁滚尿流。你可以看到这些粪便掉落到沉积物底部、海底，它们将在那里适时地被化石化，然后被玛丽·安宁发现。所以她是一个庞大的人物，但她并没有发现恐龙，因为莱姆里吉斯属于中生代的海洋，而不是陆地。所以我想问关于基督教的问题，因为我们正处于维多利亚时代中期，
the age of Darwin, but I think we should take a break. So people have got that to look forward to, which is very exciting. We'll talk about that, then we'll get into America, and then we'll talk about 20th century dinosaurs and dinosaurs' kind of metaphorical meanings and so on,
达尔文的时代，但我认为我们应该休息一下。所以大家可以期待这一点，这非常令人兴奋。我们将讨论这个，然后进入美国，接着讨论20th世纪的恐龙以及恐龙的隐喻意义等等，我们会在休息后完成所有这些，所以请不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
and we'll do all that after the break, so don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde. and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking dinosaurs and the way,
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦以及在问答环节中揭开娱乐界神秘面纱的地方，我们会告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告广播、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们正在讨论恐龙以及人们理解它们的方式的历史。所以，汤姆·霍兰，我们已经来到了19世纪中叶左右……
the history of the ways in which they've been understood. So Tom Holland, we have reached the sort of mid-19th century um there have been tremendous breakthroughs in the understanding of dinosaurs the coining of the word dinosaur for example um exhibition of kind of recreations of dinosaurs and so on so the big question is how does this affect what is a very you know god-fearing age what's the this is the age of darwinism obviously but it's also an age of tremendous sort of interest in in christianity tremendous debates and so on do dinosaurs break people's faith or do people fit them into the christian story what do they do i don't think dinosaurs per se particularly affect people i I mean, you know, Buckland, you know, has said he's become the dean of Westminster.
人们对恐龙的理解取得了巨大的突破——例如“恐龙”这个词的创造、恐龙复原模型的展览等等。所以最大的问题是，这如何影响这个极其（你知道的）敬畏上帝的时代？这是达尔文主义的时代，但显然它也是一个对基督教产生巨大兴趣、爆发巨大辩论等的时代。恐龙会打破人们的信仰吗，还是人们把它们融入了基督教的故事中？他们是怎么做的？我不认为恐龙本身对人们有什么特别的影响。我的意思是（你知道的），巴克兰（你知道的）已经成为了威斯敏斯特的院长。
It's how dinosaurs fit into Darwinism really starts to shake people's faith. Because of course, the idea that dinosaurs are, you know, which is still there in the way that we use dinosaur as a kind of pejorative to this day, this idea that there were these ancient monsters and then they became superseded because they were run out of town by evolutionary forces, which beds
恐龙如何融入达尔文主义，才真正开始动摇人们的信仰。因为当然，恐龙的观念（你知道的，直到今天我们仍在使用“恐龙”作为贬义词）——这种认为曾经有这些古代怪物，然后它们因为被进化力量逼出局而被取代的观念，
in pretty quickly because the uptick in the discovery of dinosaurs, particularly in America, coincides with the explosion of Darwinism. It's that really that unsettles people. So I'll give you an example of a man whose faith does get very radically affected by it, but it's the interplay between his discovery of dinosaurs and Darwinism. And this is a guy called Edwin Drinker Cope, who was a Quaker from Pennsylvania, who's brought up with a kind of literal belief in Genesis and the flood and all that kind of stuff. But he's also obsessed by natural history. And as the Western frontier is being pushed ever further towards the Pacific,
很快就扎根了，因为恐龙发现激增（尤其是在美国）与达尔文主义的爆发同时发生。正是这一点真正让人感到不安。所以我举一个人的例子，他的信仰确实受到了非常深刻的影响，但这是他发现恐龙与达尔文主义相互作用的结果。这个人叫埃德温·德林克·科普（Edwin Drinker Cope），他是来自宾夕法尼亚州的贵格会教徒，从小就对《创世记》、大洪水以及诸如此类的东西有着字面意义上的信仰。但他同时也对自然历史着迷。随着西部前沿不断向太平洋推进，
so he goes in its wake. So along with all the buffalo hunters and prospectors and all those kind of people. Cope is riding out into the Wild West looking for dinosaurs. And he's out there in 1877 in the Bighorn Mountains when Custer gets wiped out. And it doesn't stop him. He's dodging the Sioux war bands and so on. And he ends up having these terrible nightmares in which he, dinosaurs kind of appear and jostle him and trample him down. And I think that that's kind of expressive of this anxiety he has about whether, basically whether evolution, which he's coming to accept, can be squared with a belief in a kind of loving God.
他也随之深入。就像所有的水牛猎人、勘探者和那些人一样。科普骑马深入狂野西部寻找恐龙。1877年，当卡斯特（Custer）全军覆没时，他就在比格霍恩山脉（Bighorn Mountains）。但这并没有阻止他。他在苏族（Sioux）战团之间闪躲等等。最后他做了可怕的噩梦，在梦中恐龙出现、推挤他、践踏他。我认为这表达了他在一个问题上的焦虑：基本上是进化论（他正在开始接受它）能否与对慈爱上帝的信仰相调和。
And it imposes ever greater strains on him. And he ends up essentially, he leaves the society of friends. He gives up his, his Quaker faith. And he actually kind of becomes a racist because the only way that he can justify believing in a benefit of God is if he, he, he, he argues basically that every human, every, every living organism has a kind of end endpoint that has been defined by God. And so all species are kind of inexorably moving towards it.
这对他施加了越来越大的压力。他最终基本上离开了贵格会社团。他放弃了他的贵格会信仰。他实际上变成了一个种族主义者，因为他证明上帝的仁慈合理的唯一方法是，他基本上认为每一个人、每一个生物都有一个由上帝定义的终点。因此所有的生物都在不可避免地朝它移动。
And if that's the case, then that must be true of human beings. And therefore, you know, people like him must be way up, further up the evolutionary train than people who don't know about about evolution so he becomes kind of scientific racist basically he becomes a scientific racist despite himself i mean he doesn't want you know he has he kind of abandons his belief that all you know this quaker yeah conviction that all human beings have a kind of fundamental dignity he ends up losing it um but but um cope is also famous for what is one of his notorious rivalries in science, which he has with another American scientist, a man called Charles Othniel Marsh. And he's also going out.
如果真是这样，那对人类来说也必然如此。因此，（你知道的）像他这样的人，在进化阶梯上的位置必定远高于那些不懂进化论的人，所以他基本上变成了一个科学种族主义者。尽管他自己并不想这样——我的意思是，他并不想（你知道的）他放弃了他认为所有人（你知道的）这种贵格会关于所有人类都具有某种根本尊严的信念，他最终失去了它。但是……科普也因他在科学界的一场臭名昭著的竞争而闻名，他的对手是另一位美国科学家，一个名叫查思·奥思尼尔·马什（Charles Othniel Marsh）的人。马什也前往西部。
He's untroubled by Darwinism. And he discovers what is one of the classic proofs of it, the evolution of the horse. But Marsh also discovers an enormous number of dinosaurs so between them they're discovering loads of the classics kind of you know all the long-necked ones the sauropods triceratops all these kind of ones because it turns out and I think that this is a kind of wonderful way in which dinosaurs provide a brilliant metaphor for 19th and 20th century history. But as industrial supremacy is leeching from Britain to the United States,
他不受达尔文主义的困扰。他发现了达尔文主义的经典证明之一——马的进化。但马什也发现了数量惊人的恐龙，所以他们俩之间发现了大量的经典恐龙……（你知道的）所有长脖子的蜥脚类恐龙、三角龙以及所有这些恐龙，事实证明——我认为这是一种美妙的方式，恐龙为19和20世纪的历史提供了一个绝妙的隐喻——正如工业霸权从英国流向美国一样，
so also does the lead in paleontology, because it stands out that in the West, these lands that are being opened up by the army, there are enormous numbers of dinosaurs, and you can dig them up. Now, why is that? Is it something to do with the soil or what's the story?
古生物学的领先地位也随之转移，因为事实证明，在西部，这些被军队开辟的土地上，有数量惊人的恐龙，你可以把它们挖出来。现在，这是为什么呢？这与土壤有关，还是有什么故事？
It's to do with the geology. It's to do with the fact that, you know, there aren't kind of picturesque villages everywhere. Right. You know, you can't really find. It's right the way, so all along the Rockies, right the way up to Canada,
这与地质有关。这与这样一个事实有关，你知道，并不是到处都有那种风景如画的村庄。没错。你知道，你真的找不大到。整个洛矶山脉都是这样，一直延伸到加拿大，
there are just enormous, enormous numbers of dinosaurs waiting to be found. And Martian Cope, you know, there are so many that basically they, you know, I mean, it's kind of, it's a brilliant metaphor for American capitalism because they compete with each other so brutally. You know, they would rather smash bones up than need to be discovered by the other guy. And they end up kind of both of them kind of basically bankrupt. A monopolist moves in and buys up all their stuff. And that monopolist is Andrew Carnegie. Yeah, you couldn't make that up, could you? I mean, it's just a perfect metaphor. And Andrew Carnegie is interested. I mean, he's not interested in paleontology for his own sake. He's interested in massive dinosaurs that will make a huge statement. He wants a dinosaur that isontology for his own sake. He's interested in massive dinosaurs that will make a huge statement. He wants a dinosaur that is as big as his own kind of industrial ambitions.
有数量庞大、难以计数的恐龙正等待着被人们发现。马什和科普，你知道，数量实在是太多了，以至于它们基本上……我的意思是，这简直是美国资本主义的一个绝妙隐喻，因为他们彼此之间的竞争是如此残酷。你知道宁愿把骨头砸碎，也不愿让对方发现。结果他们两个基本上都破产了。一个垄断者介入并买下了他们所有的东西。那个垄断者就是安德鲁·卡内基。是的，你简直不敢相信，对吧？我的意思是，这真是一个完美的隐喻。安德鲁·卡内基很感兴趣。我的意思是，他不是出于对古生物学本身的兴趣。他感兴趣的是那些能产生巨大轰动的巨型恐龙。他想要一只像他自己的那种工业野心一样庞大的恐龙。
And so he buys one called Diplodocus that is the, at that point, the longest dinosaur that had ever been discovered. He buys it up. He names it after himself. Why do you say Diplodocus and not Diplodocus? I don't know. I just always know okay i i was just brought up as a diplodocus man and i've tried to instill that in in youngsters that i meet but um do you know i i don't know what the correct pronunciation is okay this is a sort of
因此，他买下了一只名叫梁龙（Diplodocus）的恐龙，在当时，这是人们发现的体型最长的恐龙。他把它买了下来。他用自己的名字为它命名。为什么你发音是 Diplodocus 而不是 Diplodocus？我不知道。我只是从小就习惯了……好吧，我从小就被当成一个“Diplodocus”派来培养的，我一直试图向我遇到的年轻人灌输这一点，但是……你知道，我不知道正确的发音是什么。好吧，这有点像
cope marsh type uh feud so and then what what carnegie does is he he makes casts of it and he sends it first of all, to London. So that's the one that was in the Natural History Museum for a long time. Yeah, which we all remember, you know, yeah. But he does other casts and he sends it round. So it's a kind of wonderful illustration of the way, you know, Carnegie himself is from Scotland originally. So it's this, the industry is passing from the old world to the new and the new is now starting to export it back to the old. It's kind of a perfect illustration of it.
科普和马什式的……呃……宿怨。接下来，卡内基所做的是，他制作了它的模型，并首先把它送到了伦敦。所以，这就是那只在自然历史博物馆放了很久的模型。是的，我们都记得，对吧，是的。但他还制作了其他模型并四处发送。所以这很好地说明了这样一种方式，你知道，卡内基本人最初来自苏格兰。所以，工业正从旧世界传向新世界，而新世界现在又开始将它出口回旧世界。这可以说是它的一个完美例证。
It's that at this point, the idea of dinosaurs as slow, lumbering, dumb, hopeless creatures that have gone extinct because they've been wiped out by mammals hasn't kicked in yet. fine for for kamegi to associate a dinosaur with his own industrial concerns as it is with with the the sinclair oil company which takes as its logo a sauropod a dinosaur and and we're about to get to the point of with t-rex aren't we the discovery of tyrannosaurus rex and this extraordinary man barnum brown who went around in long fur coats and was a great sort of a great sort of showman so what's the story with him is Is he a real paleontologist? Or the very word Barnum kind of makes me think he's just running a circus or something. Well, he's from the Dutch History Museum in New York.
正是在这个时候，将恐龙视为行动迟缓、笨拙、愚蠢、无可救药的生物的观点——它们因为被哺乳动物消灭而灭绝——还没有形成。卡内基将恐龙与他自己的工业利益联系起来，就像辛克莱石油公司（Sinclair Oil Company）将其作为标志一样，该公司以蜥脚类恐龙作为标志，而我们即将谈到霸王龙，对吧？——也就是暴龙的发现，还有这位非凡的巴纳姆·布朗（Barnum Brown），他总是穿着长皮大衣，是个非常了不起的、极具表演天赋的人。那么关于他的故事是什么？他是一个真正的古生物学家吗？还是说“巴纳姆”这个名字让我觉得他只是在经营马戏团什么的？哦，他来自纽约的荷兰历史博物馆（注：此处原文如此或口误，应为美国自然历史博物馆）。
Mr. Bones. Don't they call him Mr. Bones? Well, he's a showman in the way that, you know, I mean, this is still kind of the age where the mythology of the West is still incredibly current. And he makes play with it. And he is the Eastern gentleman going out West. So that's why he's wearing a fur coat.
“骨头先生”。人们不是叫他“骨头先生”吗？嗯，他是个极具表演才华的人，你知道的，我的意思是，这仍然是一个西部神话依然非常盛行的时代。他很好地利用了这一点。他是一个前往西部的东部绅士。这就是为什么他穿着皮大衣。
And also, he's incredibly predatory because he discovers actually that the best fossil deposits are up in Canada. And that in no way stops him from taking all the bones and sending them to new york and you're starting to get the sense that um you know america's global ambitions are manifesting themselves through the appetite of american paleontologists for fossils so you've got you've got barnum brown kind of digging up t-rexes such like creatures all the way up the west deep into canada yeah and then in the 20s you have this guy roy chapman andrews who is the guy who discovers the protoceratops eggs so he goes on a series of kind of amazing expeditions to the flaming cliffs in the goby desert uh and he it is said i don't
而且，他极其具有掠夺性，因为他实际上发现最好的化石沉积物在加拿大。但这丝毫不能阻止他把所有的骨头都拿走并运到纽约。你开始有一种感觉，嗯，你知道，美国的全球野心正在通过美国古生物学家对化石的胃口显现出来。所以你有巴纳姆·布朗那样的人，一直到西部深处、深入加拿大去挖掘霸王龙之类的生物，是的。然后在20世纪20年代，你有了罗伊·查普曼·安德鲁斯（Roy Chapman Andrews）这个人，他就是在戈壁沙漠的火焰崖进行了一系列惊人探险、发现了原角龙蛋的人，传说他……我
know how accurately is one of the models for indiana jones he's uh you know he's got a whip and he's frightened of snakes, fights Nazis. All that kind of stuff. So it's a kind of, you know, it's still, it's something that men of action want to be associated with. But again, to pursue this idea that dinosaurs provide a metaphor for the process of capitalism and industrialisation, in the Great Crash, so in the Depression,
不知道准确度如何……是印第安纳·琼斯的原型之一。他……你知道，他拿着鞭子，害怕蛇，与纳粹战斗。诸如此类的事情。所以这是一种……你知道，这仍然是那种行动派男人想要与之联系在一起的东西。但同样，为了延续这样一个观点：恐龙为资本主义和工业化进程提供了一个隐喻，在大萧条时期，
you increasingly start to get the sense that actually dinosaurs are a bit of a dead end that they are properly for children and that dinosaurs themselves are kind of evolutionary dead ends that that don't really matter they're ponderous and slow and lumbering and i think that that's an image of them it's still kind of just about current to this day to pick up one of our previous podcasts in golden eye m calls james bond a racist misogynist dinosaur because dinosaurs were neither racist nor misogynist were they but um well to to go from bond to something he knew a lot about the cold war there comes to be this interesting kind of thing with communist and capitalist dinosaurs
你越来越开始有一种感觉，即实际上恐龙有点像死胡同，它们确实只适合小孩子，而且恐龙本身就是某种进化的死胡同，并没有真正的重要性，它们沉重、缓慢而笨拙。我认为这种形象至今依然存在。就像我们之前的播客中提到的，在《黄金眼》中，M把詹姆斯·邦德称为一个种族主义的、厌女的恐龙，因为恐龙既不是种族主义者也不是厌女症患者，对吧？但是……嗯，从邦德转到他非常了解的冷战话题上，共产主义恐龙和资本主义恐龙之间出现了一种有趣的现象，
doesn't there so so in the soviet union dinosaurs or are imagined differently from how they are in the west yes so if you think the the classic image of of a mesozoic scene which has been replayed in in countless numbers of films uh the classic image perhaps is a tyrannosaur against a triceratops you always get you know the triceratops with the three horns the tyrannosaur with the giant teeth and they fight each other and in in the kind of the classic american illustrations you have a t-rex you have a triceratops and it's like a kind of shootout in some wild west town outside the saloon it's the sheriff against the bad guy who's the sheriff the triceratops yes i guess the triceratops is the sheriff he's seeing he's
不是吗？所以……所以在苏联，恐龙的想象方式与在西方不同。是的，所以如果你想想中生代场景的经典形象——它在无数的电影中被重现过——最经典的形象或许是一只霸王龙对阵一只三角龙。你总会看到……你知道，长着三只角的三角龙，长着巨大牙齿的霸王龙，它们互相搏斗。在某种经典的美国插图中，你有一只霸王龙，你有一只三角龙，这就好像是西部牛仔小镇里沙龙外面的一场枪战。谁是治安官？三角龙。是的，我猜三角龙是治安官。他在对付……
seeing off the uh yeah the battle rustler um in the Soviet Union uh there was a famous artist artist called Konstantin Konstantinovich Flyerov and he in in um during operation Barbarossa as the the Nazis were laying siege to Leningrad he was in Leningrad I think or maybe he was in Moscow I can't remember anyway he's in one of them and he did a spectacular illustration of a T-Rex triceratops face-off. What he did was to have a whole number of triceratopses, and they've kind of formed a phalanx so that their horns bristle like spears. And there are three kind of predatory tyrannosaurs circling it, but they can't break in. So unlike in the American where you have triceratops as a kind of lone gun,
呃，对付牛贼。在苏联，有一位著名的艺术家叫康斯坦丁·康斯坦丁诺维奇·弗利亚罗夫（Konstantin Konstantinovich Flyerov），在巴巴罗萨行动期间，当纳粹对列宁格勒进行围困时，他在列宁格勒，我想，或者也许在莫斯科，我记不清了。不管怎样，他在其中一个城市，他画了一幅非常壮观的霸王龙对决三角龙的插图。他画的是一大群三角龙，它们组成了一个方阵，它们的角像长矛一样怒张。周围有三只凶猛的霸王龙在盘旋，但它们无法突破。所以，与美国版本中三角龙作为孤胆枪手不同，
in the Soviet version, they're a collective. Because the Soviet army gets to see off Hitler, so the triceratops get to see off tyrannosaurs. And I think it does show how readily the prehistoric world lends itself to all kinds of metaphors like that but the the field of understanding dinosaurs i mean the history of it is as you've shown fascinating but didn't stop being fascinating did it because i'm all right thinking in the 60s and 70s or maybe maybe i'm a bit early maybe 70s and 80s there were huge kind of convulsions in the study of dinosaurs so people had thought they were cold-blooded and then they thought they were warm-blooded they had thought they're reptiles and then they basically think they're birds you must know tons about this because you're very into this dinosaurs and birds business aren't you well you you you quoted bob backer at the beginning of this episode
在苏联的版本中，它们是一个集体。因为苏联军队能够击退希特勒，所以三角龙也能击退霸王龙。我认为这确实表明史前世界是多么容易为各种这样的隐喻提供借口。但是理解恐龙的领域——我的意思是它的历史，正如你所展示的那样，令人着迷——并没有停止迷人，对吧？因为我觉得在60年代和70年代，或者可能我有点早，也许是70年代和80年代，对恐龙的研究发生了巨大的剧变：人们曾以为它们是冷血动物，然后又认为它们是温血动物；人们曾以为它们是爬行动物，然后基本上认为它们是鸟类。你一定对这些了如指掌，因为你对恐龙和鸟类的关系非常感兴趣，对吧？
and he he wrote a famous book called the dinosaur heresies in which absolutely you say he argued that dinosaurs were warm-blooded that they were mobile that they were incredibly successful um at the back of this was a discovery made in the 60s of a dinosaur called dynonychus actually dynonychus has been discovered earlier but it's it's a guy called john ostrom argues that dynonychus means terrible claw and these were very mobile they they seemed to attack in packs they could they could run they could jump so they were the opposite of Ponderous. And he extrapolated from this an argument that dinosaurs were just kind of basically terrifying. And it's Deinonychus that is Velociraptor in Jurassic Park, because Velociraptor sounds more frightening. And also, obviously, Deinonyanaicus bears a very strong resemblance to
是的，你在本集节目开始时引用了鲍勃·巴克（Bob Bakker）的话，
birds and this was something that that wasn't original to ostrom actually thomas huxley who was darwin's bulldog yes a good titanic figure of late victorian science he had argued that the birds were basically dinosaurs but that was that was an argument that got parked but it gets revived in the 60s and essentially now people would say so that backer passage you know he says dinosaurs are extinct i think most people now most scientists and i speak completely as a non-scientist would say that dinosaurs aren't extinct because birds are dinosaurs so they're still around so they're all the old stuff about about the death of the dinosaurs is overheated. And so that is the other thing that happened,
这并不是奥斯特罗姆原创的。事实上，达尔文的斗犬托马斯·亨利·H·赫胥黎（Thomas Henry Huxley）——维多利亚时代晚期科学界的泰斗——曾争辩说鸟类基本上就是恐龙，但那个观点被搁置了。不过它在60年代被重新提起，基本上现在人们会说——所以巴克的那段话，你知道，他说恐龙已经灭绝了。我想现在大多数人，大多数科学家——我完全以非科学家的身份发言——会说恐龙并没有灭绝，因为鸟类就是恐龙，所以它们依然存在。因此，所有关于恐龙灭绝的旧说法都被夸大了。所以，发生的事情还有另一个，
was that the great mystery for a century and more was what happened to the dinosaurs. Where did they go? Why did they become extinct? And so you had all the Gary Larson, the famous Gary Larson cartoon, terrible news guys, we've got brains the size of a walnut and there are loads of mammals taking over um that that was that was basically why people thought
一个世纪或更长时间以来的巨大谜团是恐龙究竟发生了什么。它们去哪儿了？为什么它们灭绝了？所以你会有加里·拉森（Gary Larson）那些著名的加里·拉森漫画：“可怕的消息，伙计们，我们的大脑只有核桃那么大，而且有大量的哺乳动物正在接管……”——这基本上就是人们认为
that they were kind of hopeless in the dead end but but it was in in the 80s so in 81 a brother and father team of geologists in alvarez pair a feast identified identified this kind of strain in the sediment at the end of the Cretaceous period when the dinosaurs go extinct of iridium, which seemed to imply that there'd been a kind of an asteroid hit. And they argued that this perhaps was what had killed the dinosaurs. And this was a theory that got kind of stress tested and stress tested and stress tested. And ultimately, I mean, pretty quickly came to be almost universally accepted. that got kind of stress tested and stress tested and stress tested and and ultimately i mean pretty quickly came to be almost universally accepted and the impact point got discovered it's it's um in
它们是无可救药的死胡同的原因。但正是在80年代——1981年，阿尔瓦雷斯（Alvarez）父子地质学家团队在白垩纪末期恐龙灭绝的沉积物中识别出这种铱元素，这似乎暗示曾有过一次小行星撞击。他们认为这可能就是杀死恐龙的原因。这个理论经过了一次又一次、一次又一次的压力测试。最终——而且很快——几乎被普遍接受。撞击点被发现了，它在
in mexico and essentially the dinosaurs went extinct due to bad luck but they didn't go extinct if they're still around flying around the non-avian dinosaurs right went extinct due to bad luck. So you have this combination of the realisation that dinosaurs have been mobile, lots of them perhaps have been warm-blooded, that they were basically birds, combined with the sense that the fact they'd gone extinct wasn't really their fault, which was all of which fused just in time for Spielberg's film Jurassic Park. So Michael Crichton's novel novel which predates it obviously um a seismically important film because it portrayed dinosaurs in a way that was as true to how the kind of cutting-edge understanding of paleontology
墨西哥。基本上，恐龙是因为运气不好而灭绝的。但如果它们依然存在并在四处飞翔，那么非鸟类恐龙就没有真正灭绝，对吧？是因为运气不好而灭绝的。所以你有了这样一种结合：认识到恐龙曾是活跃的，其中许多可能是温血动物，它们基本上就是鸟类；再加上这样一种感觉，即它们灭绝的事实其实并不是它们的错。所有这些恰好在斯皮尔伯格的电影《侏罗纪公园》上映前夕融合在了一起。所以迈克尔·克莱顿（Michael Crichton）的小说——当然先于电影出版——是一部具有里程碑意义的重要电影，因为它对恐龙的描绘尽可能贴近当时最前沿的古生物学理解，
as as was possible so they move in herds, they are clever, they're ingenious. But they're all studded. I don't know if you remember, there's a bit where the children that you always get in Spielberg film, they're hiding in, I think, in a kitchen or something. Yeah, very famous.
它们成群结队行动，它们很聪明，它们极具智谋。但它们都被……我不知道你记不记得，有个片段是斯皮尔伯格电影中总会出现的小孩，他们藏在，我想是在厨房里什么的。是的，非常著名。
And the Velociraptor blows on the glass and it steams up. So you know that you're doing something very frightening. And then they work out how to open the door. And there's kind of another amazing scene where they break into the lab where they've been extracting the DNA
然后那只迅猛龙对着玻璃呼气，玻璃上布满了水汽。所以你知道正在发生非常可怕的事情。接着它们想出了如何开门。还有另一个令人惊叹的场景，它们闯入了提取DNA的实验室，
and the kind of computer code is luminous and green and it kind of spills over the head of Velociraptor. And again, it's doing what has happened back with the uh the crystal palace it's it's casting dinosaurs as cutting edge you know these are creatures that you can link with computing and with dna and with yeah absolutely cutting edge theme parks so so jurassic park is kind of absolutely the heir to the crystal palace although Although Jurassic Park, it's interesting you say that because Jurassic Park kind of cuts against
那种计算机代码发出荧光绿色，洒在迅猛龙的头上。这再次呼应了水晶宫（Crystal Palace）时期所做的事情——它将恐龙塑造成最前沿的事物（你知道，这些是可以与计算机、DNA以及……是的，绝对是最前沿的主题公园联系在一起的生物）。所以《侏罗纪公园》绝对是水晶宫的继承者，尽管《侏罗纪公园》——有趣的是你这么说，因为《侏罗纪公园》在某种程度上违背了
much of what we've been talking about, which is the advance of science, fantastic potential of science and human curiosity to find out about what went before. I mean, Jurassic Park is all about the dangers of science, isn't it? Rather than so much specifically the dangers of dinosaurs, it's that kind of, you know, Frankenstein's kind of science run amok, isn't it?
我们一直在谈论的许多内容，也就是科学的进步、科学和人类好奇心去探索过去的巨大潜力。我的意思是，《侏罗纪公园》讲的全是科学的危险，对吧？与其说是具体针对恐龙的危险，不如说那是弗兰肯斯坦式的、失控的科学，对吧？
Yes, it is. I mean, it is the Frankenstein story. And if you go to a theme park, I mean, you know that everything's going to go wrong. I mean, the same is true as you go to a cowboy theme park. Yeah, Westworld. You know the gunslingers are going to come after you. I did not take away from watching Jurassic Park, ooh, we shouldn't try and bring dinosaurs back.
是的，确实如此。我的意思是，这就是弗兰肯斯坦的故事。如果你去一个主题公园，我的意思是，你知道一切都会出岔子。我的意思是，你去一个牛仔主题公园也是如此。是的，《西部世界》。你知道那些快枪手会来找你的。我从看《侏罗纪公园》中得到的体会并不是“哦，我们不应该尝试把恐龙带回现实”。
I took away, it would be amazing. You're the Richard Attenborough figure. I'm Geoff Goldblum. So the kind of, the stop-start technology that they used in, you know, Millennials BC, those kind of films, was appropriate to the kind of dinosaur people understood then,
我的体会是“这太了不起了”。你就是理查德·阿滕伯格（Richard Attenborough）饰演的角色。我是杰夫·高布伦（Jeff Goldblum）。所以，在《公元前一百万年》这类电影中使用的那种停格动画技术，适合当时人们所理解的恐龙形象，
slow, ponderous, sluggish. The fact that you had CGI and that Jurassic Park was the first film to use CGI to bring dinosaurs to life, I mean, you remember the scene where they, Samuel and Laura Dern are going along in the jeep
缓慢、沉重、迟钝。而你拥有了CGI（计算机生成图像），《侏罗纪公园》是第一部使用CGI将恐龙带入现实的电影——我的意思是，你还记得那个场景吗：山姆（Sam）和劳拉·邓恩（Laura Dern）坐着吉普车前行，
and then they turn around and they kind of take their shades off and their hats and gaze in wonder, and then you look and there's the brachios all coming out and i i mean i i felt i felt that just seeing it in cgi and i never imagined i'd see a dinosaur that brilliantly brought to life and it kind of turbo charged for lots and lots of people study of dinosaurs and ironically one of the things that it did so at the end of jurassic park they're flying out in the helicopter they've had a terrible time and sam neill says to richard attenborough he's not going to approve the park and then they look out and they see a flock of
然后他们转过身，摘下墨镜和帽子，惊叹不已，接着你看过去，有一只腕龙走了出来。我的意思是，我当时觉得，仅仅看到它用CGI呈现，我从没想过能看到一只被如此完美、生动地带入现实的恐龙，这为许许多多研究恐龙的人注入了强大的动力。讽刺的是，它所做的事情之一是——在《侏罗纪公园》的结尾，他们乘直升机飞离，经历了一段可怕的时光，山姆·尼尔（Sam Neill）对理查德·阿滕伯格说他不会批准这个公园，然后他们向外望去，看到一群
birds going across the sea and the implication is obviously that that birds are dinosaurs and at the point that was still not a universally accepted thesis. But in the years that followed, I mean, actually almost immediately, a series of incredible finds began to be made in China. And these were finds that showed conclusively that lots of dinosaurs had been feathered and that basically, you know, there was a whole line of dinosaurs that had become birds. The effect of that was that for the first time, you know, in over 100 years, the most interesting center of dinosaur discoveries and finds and research was no longer the United States, but China. There's another metaphor.
鸟儿飞过海面，其暗示显而易见，即鸟类就是恐龙。在当时，这还不是一个被普遍接受的论点。但在随后的几年里——事实上几乎是立刻——中国开始出土一系列令人惊叹的化石。这些发现确凿地表明，许多恐龙都长有羽毛，基本上，你知道，有一整支恐龙演化成了鸟类。其结果是，一百多年来，中国第一次取代了美国，成为了最令人瞩目的恐龙发现、出土和研究中心。这又是一个隐喻。
Absolutely. There's another amazing metaphor. It's kind of very odd that if you think of, you know, the lead passes from Britain to America and then to China, the same thing happens with dinosaur discoveries. And the degree to which that is just a metaphor, whether there's something deeper. Yeah. And what about, obviously, we are living in an age where we're so much more conscious of geological time,
绝对的。这又是一个了不起的隐喻。非常奇怪的是，如果你想想，你知道，领先地位从英国传递到美国，然后又传到了中国，恐龙的发现也发生了同样的事情。这种现象在多大程度上仅仅是一个隐喻，还是其中有着更深层次的东西。是的。还有，显然我们生活在一个对地质时间、
of the Earth, the changing climate, all those kinds of things. So where does that leave dinosaurs? I mean, obviously they're no longer these kind of, well, for children, they still are, aren't they? They're mythical monsters, Tyrannosaurus Rex, you know. But I think for adults and for people who are interested in dinosaurs, they now have a very different role in our imagination than they did 50 or 100 years ago. Is that right? Well, you still get dinosaurs being used as a pejorative. Yeah.
地球、不断变化的气候等所有这些问题都有着更深意识的时代。那么这把恐龙置于何地？我的意思是，它们显然不再是这种……好吧，对小孩子来说它们依然是，对吧？它们是神话中的怪物，比如霸王龙，你知道的。但我认为对于成年人和对恐龙感兴趣的人来说，它们在我们想象中扮演的角色现在与50或100年前截然不同。是这样吗？嗯，你仍然会听到人们把恐龙当成贬义词来使用。是的。
That is still kind of current. So when I make a reference to Jordan, the reality TV show star on our podcast, you mock me as a dinosaur you probably i think you call me granddad but i felt the dinosaurs hanging in the hanging in the air i would never have used that i hope i did because i know better because actually and i think i think i think it's an understanding of dinosaurs that has percolated through because i think that a crucial part of anxiety about climate change and about mass extinction that is going on at the moment has been hugely hugely sharpened by the sense that the mesozoic ended in a kind of
这种现象依然存在。所以当我在我们的播客中提到现实秀明星乔丹（Jordan）时，你嘲笑我像个恐龙——你大概……我想你叫我老头子，但我感觉恐龙这个词依然挥之不去。我绝不会那样用，希望我没有，因为我更懂分寸。因为实际上——而且我认为，我认为这也是一种已经渗透进来的对恐龙的理解，因为我认为目前人们对气候变化和大灭绝的焦虑中，至关重要的一部分被这样一种观念极大、极大程度地强化了：中生代以一种
catastrophic with a catastrophic ball of fire that the seas boiled the flesh fell off the bones that um whatever the 94 95 of all living organisms were wiped out from the blink of an eye because it it has brought home i suppose the um you know how vulnerable earth is so it's almost a story about it's a story about hubris to some extent is it it's a story about inevitable disaster looming it's the apocalypse is coming the end of the world is nigh don't you think that's that's shot the dinosaur story shot through with that? I do. So I think that, you know, to go back to Christianity, if there's a beginning, then there's an end. And I think that the dinosaur, you know, the kind of so many illustrations of the asteroid
灾难性的火球宣告结束，海洋沸腾，血肉剥落骨骼，无论如何，百分之九十四、九十五的生物在眨眼之间就被消灭了——因为它让我们深刻体会到，我猜，地球是多么脆弱。所以这几乎是一个关于……在某种程度上这是一个关于傲慢的故事，对吧？这是一个关于不可避免的灾难逼近的故事，末日即将来临，世界末日近在眼前。你不觉得恐龙的故事贯穿着这种色彩吗？我是这么认为的。所以我觉得，你知道，回到基督教的观点，如果有了一个开始，就会有一个结束。而且我认为恐龙——你知道，那种小行星撞击的许多插画，
hitting and a kind of pterosaur looking or a tyrannosaur glancing around and there's a plume of light. It gives us a kind of scientifically updated vision of Apocalypse, of the end of the world. Except of course it's not the end of the world because then life covers, you know, life has a way. There's a Jurassic Park. I think the complication for us is that it forces us to ask now, are we the asteroid? Are we the asteroid? Yes. Are we the asteroid? It's Is Homo sapiens the asteroid? And it's the process of industrialisation brought to life, you know, facilitating the discovery of dinosaurs, that is now perhaps leading to global catastrophe.
以及某种翼龙在张望或霸王龙环顾四周，空中升起一缕强光——它为我们提供了一种经过科学更新的末日愿景、世界末日的愿景。当然，除非这并不是世界末日，因为随后生命覆盖了……你知道，生命总会找到出路。《侏罗纪公园》里就是这么说的。我认为对我们来说复杂的是，它迫使我们现在去问：我们就是那颗小行星吗？我们就是那颗小行星吗？是的。我们就是那颗小行星吗？智人就是那颗小行星吗？正是被带入现实的工业化进程——它促成了恐龙的发现——现在可能正通向全球灾难。
That's a lovely, cheerful note on which to end. Everything has a beginning, everything has an end. But we should end with one last question, very much in the spirit of the podcast. Martin Perry, who would win in a fight
这是一个多么美妙、欢快且适合作为结束语的基调。万物皆有始，万物皆有终。但我们应该以最后一个问题来结束，这非常符合本播客的精神。马丁·佩里（Martin Perry），在一场战斗中谁会赢：
between a Tyrannosaurus and a Stegosaurus? Well, neither would because they didn't coexist. That's like Mary Beard being evasive about Alexander the Great versus Julius Caesar.
霸王龙还是剑龙？嗯，谁都不会赢，因为它们根本没有在同一时期共存。这就像玛丽·比尔德（Mary Beard）对亚历山大大帝对阵尤利乌斯·恺撒的问题含糊其辞一样。
Tyrannosaurs are closer to us than Stegosaurs were to Tyrannosaurs. That's a fascinating, that's a fantastic fact, isn't it? That's like Cleopatra was closer to us than she was to the building of the Great Pyramid.
霸王龙距离我们比剑龙距离霸王龙更近。这是一个令人着迷、非常了不起的事实，对吧？这就好比克莉奥帕特拉（埃及艳后）距离我们比她距离胡夫大金字塔的建造还要近。
One of those amazing... So... I imagine a tyrannosaur would win. Would it? So was a tyrannosaur... The general sense now is that the tyrannosaur was actually completely useless. Is that right?
其中一个令人惊叹的……所以……我猜霸王龙会赢。是吗？那么霸王龙……现在的普遍看法是，霸王龙其实完全毫无用处。是这样吗？
Or was that just overstated? Yeah, massively overstated. No, not useless. I'm glad we're clear. You would not want to be bitten by a tyrannosaur. Well, since we don't coexist, I'm pretty confident that's not want to be bitten by a dinosaur well since we don't co-exist I'm pretty confident that's not going to happen right on that bombshell
还是说这被大大夸大了？是的，被大大夸大了。不，并非毫无用处。我很高兴我们弄清楚了这一点。你可不想被霸王龙咬一口。嗯，既然我们没有共存，我相当确信那不会发生。好啦，带着这个重磅炸弹，
I think we shall thank you Tom for that tour de force I did all so much talking in Watergate it was nice to have a rest this time and it is a fascinating it's a fascinating subject we have coming up remind me what we have coming up on
我想我们该谢谢汤姆带给我们这场精彩绝伦的讨论。我在《水门事件》里说了那么多话，这次能休息一下真好，而且这是一个迷人的、即将来临的话题。提醒我一下，我们接下来在
thursday we have a history of india in 10 buildings and then we will be back next week with golden ages when was the golden age and is there such a thing right we'll see you next time goodbye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
周四要谈论什么？我们将讲述十座建筑里的印度史，然后下周我们将带着“黄金时代”回归：什么是黄金时代？真的有黄金时代这种东西吗？好的，我们下期见，再见！感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。